situation inquiétante en côte d'ivoire
avec des tensions post électorale
alassana ouattara remporté la
présidentielle du 31 octobre selon la
commission électorale indépendante le
pays attend désormais la proclamation de
sa victoire par la cour
constitutionnelle l'opposition qui a
boycotté le scrutin annoncé un
gouvernement de transition civile
le pic plusieurs canons ont été arrêtés
elle dénonce une tentative
d'intimidation
le pouvoir lui dénonce une sédition
écoutez adama bictogo et des secrétaires
exécutifs du rhdp
des propos recueillis hier par nos
envoyées spéciales en côte d'ivoire
samantha ronson ou non mais nous n'avons
pas des tensions politiques ou quoi ou
voulu absolument instaurer une tension
politique qui a eu des élections
il ya eu un bon déroulement du scrutin
il ya eu quelques bureaux une abeille de
vote mais ceci étant il ya eu un bon
déroulement du scrutin le président
alassane ouattara a été élu avec 53% 90
de toutes parts c'est parce que je vous
rappelle que en 2000 il ya eu 37
en 2000 il ya eu 37 % de taux de
participation
en 2015 le taux de participation alors
que le président bédié
guillaume soro ça faisait partie du rhdp
mabri il ya eu 52 % taux de
participation le les suffrages exprimés
en 2020 en faveur du président alassane
ouattara sont au delà des suffrages
exprimés en sa faveur au ciné en 2010
qu'en 2000 guest